Hello. Hello.
Welcome to the table, everybody.
Glad you could be here. Hi, Finley.
Glad you're here.
And um we are really, really grateful
that you're here. Whether this is your
first time here or you've been here for
a long time or it's your first time in a
long time, thank you for joining us at
the table. And um we just want to kick
our service off here with a few
announcements and um let you guys kind
of know what's happening in our
community and then I'll um start our
call to worship as well. So um the first
thing is actually an announcement for
next Sunday a week from today we will be
having our uh byianual is that how you
say that every six months state of the
table meeting which just means that it's
a time for the leadership of the church
to share with our um community sort of
how we're doing as a church where we've
been for the last six months and where
we see things headed in the next six
months. So, it covers things like, you
know, budgets, it covers events, it
covers leadership transitions, any kind
of, you know, infrastructure things that
you'd like to know about what's
happening at the table. And we're going
to do that in this room next Sunday, one
hour before the service starts. So,
we're trying to make that as convenient
as possible so people could just come
early who want to kind of get the lay of
the land and hear what's going on.
That's 4 o'clock next Sunday in this
room and it's open to all. um whether
you're a member here or not. And um it
it is sort of like our church business
meeting. For those of you who are not
members or who are just checking us out
and have only been around for a short
while but would like to know more about
the table, we actually have another
announcement for the following Sunday
where we will be holding a welcome to
the table class and it's sort of just an
introduction for people to find out more
of our story, where we came from, who we
are, our values, and for you to kind of
get the lay of the land here. So, if
you're new and um you know, would like
more information on the table, we invite
you to join us for that. That's actually
from 3:30, no, sorry, 3:00 to 4:30. Um
and like I said, that's two weeks from
today on September 28th. So, um you it
is not like a membership sign up, just
so you know. But if you're like, I've
been here for a while and I've thought
about becoming a member, that would be
the next step for you as well. So, um,
the third announcement is actually for
our kids and our families with kids. We
are going to have a fall fest and my
family is going to host that at our
house here in Saxi. And it's going to be
um some games. We're going to do for
those of you who can hold a knife, we're
going to do a pumpkin carving contest.
For those of you who should not hold
knives, we're going to do pumpkin
painting. Um, but we'll have some games
and some snacks. And that's actually
October 17th. So, it's the perfect
opportunity. Bring a pumpkin along if
you want to do carving. We'll have small
pumpkins provided that kids can paint,
but if you want to do the large pumpkin
and enter the pumpkin carving contest,
BYOP. Okay. So, it should be fun. And um
just save the date for that. We'll have
a sign up for that starting at the
beginning of October. Um but we just
want to get that on your calendar. Okay.
Next thing, the sixth anniversary of the
table is coming up the first week of
November. And to celebrate, I know,
right?
We're still here.
Um, to celebrate that, we're actually
going to do an annual chili cookoff that
we've done in years past. Um, and it'll
be for our service on November the 2nd.
So, if you would like to sign up to be
part of that chili cookoff, please scan
that QR code so that you can go ahead
and sign up and let us know you're
bringing your chili and uh we'll make
sure that there's enough food for
everyone. Um we are the table. We really
like eating together. Okay, that's just
part of who we are. So, um if if you
don't like eating, you know, you can
leave.
Um no, just joking. But
um okay to wind it down. If this is your
first time to be in a service for a long
time and you maybe have some strong
feelings or anxiety or not sure how you
feel about that or maybe you have um a
need where you feel fidgety or um they
we have a bucket over here on this table
that has some fidgets in it, some
coloring sheets, some ways that you
could keep your hands busy during the
service or anything that we could do to
just help you feel at ease and relax. I
think it has some earplugs as well if it
just feels too loud in the room.
anything we could do to make you more
comfortable. So, feel free to um visit
our accessibility bucket over there. And
um having said that, I'd like to move
into our call to worship. So, um if
you'll just center your heart with me
here.
Now, we exit the kingdom of noise, of
hurry, and of productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
of stillness and simplicity,
sacred space.
A place for prayer, for worship, and for
adoration,
a place to behold Christ, the revelation
of God, the heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart.
May we all come home.
Thanks, Maggie. If you guys want to
stand with us, we are going to start off
with some music tonight.
And if it's your first time, yes, Maggie
and I are twins, so you are not seeing
double.
All right. Um, Miles is on guitar
tonight. He is graciously jumps in on an
instrument that he doesn't normally play
up here. So you guys sing out and be
very supportive and
um give us all the love from out there.
But we are truly a community and we're
coming together in worship um not as a
performance but as a moment where we can
join in and speak out these truths that
we believe um are real. So you guys fill
that space as much as you are
comfortable doing.
All right.
[Music]
Let the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run, the fountain I drink from.
Oh, he is my song.
Let the king of my heart be the shed
where I hide, the ransom for my life.
Oh, he is my song. You are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good.
You're good.
Oh,
let the key of my heart be the man by my
s, the anchor in the waves, oh my soul.
Let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins. The echo of my days
always mine. Let's sing that one more
time. Let the king of my heart be the
wind inside my sails, the anor in the
waves, always my soul.
Let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins.
The echo of my name, always my soul. You
are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good. You're good.
you are good.
You're good.
>> You're never going to let You're never
going to let me down.
>> You're never going to You're never going
to let me down.
You're never going to let You're never
going to let me down.
>> You're never going to let You're never
You're never going to let You're never
going to let me down. You are good.
You're good.
Oh,
you are good. You're good.
>> you're never going to let You're never
going to let me down.
You're never going to let You're never
>> You're never going to let You're never
going to let me down.
You're never going to let You're never
You're good.
You are good.
[Music]
You're good.
Oh,
you are
[Music]
good.
All right, kiddos. It's time for you
guys to go to your classes so y'all can
meet your teachers over there by the
double doors.
And thank you so much
and Katie and Abby,
everyone who's helping in kids ministry
tonight. We really appreciate you guys.
And we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people. So if this is
your first week, you can follow along on
the screens. Um the parts that are in
red, we will read aloud together. And
then we'll leave space in the middle for
you to lift up anything that you might
be carrying into this room tonight.
Whether it's a person or a situation
that's on your heart, we just want to
lift that up before God together
for this city of Saxi, Texas, and for
every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us, and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you. Lord, we know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life. and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence. Amen.
We're going to move on to a song called
Goodness of God. And I just wanted to
quickly say
this song has not always been one that I
can sing real honestly. Um there was a
season in my life where I was really
grieving and these felt almost me.
Um, but the song that comes after this
one is called It Is Well.
And one of the things that I really love
about Psalm 23 is that you have this um
David is the writer of Psalm 23 and he's
starting it out by saying, "The Lord is
my shepherd. I shall not want. He makes
me lie down in green pastures. He leads
me beside still waters." yada yada yada,
all the good stuff. But then you get
down and it says, "Even though I walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death, I will fear no evil.
Even though I walk through the valley of
the shadow of death, that's not a happy
place. That's not a good time." And I'm
sure there was a lot of grieving going
on for him to be able to write those
words. And if you know the story of
David, you know, he was sought after by
armies and persecuted. And I mean, he
had some some rough times. Um, and yet
he's writing this passage that starts
out with, "The Lord is my shepherd." And
then it ends with, "Surely goodness and
love will follow me all the days of my
life, and I'll dwell in the house of the
Lord forever." And it was just a
reminder to me that things go in tandem
that sometimes seem like they shouldn't.
We can have both grief and joy.
We can say goodbye to people while also
opening our hearts and saying hello to
others. We can let things go that are
painful and accept something new and
believe that God has a plan.
So tonight when we sing these words,
maybe you're in a season of grief. Maybe
it's hard to say, "All my life you've
been faithful. All my life you've been
so so good." Maybe tonight those words
don't always really ring true. But for
me, what's been really beautiful is to
remember passages like Psalm 23 and be
able to say, "Though I walk through the
valley of the shadow of death, I will
not fear because you are with me." And
that's the God that we worship tonight.
A God who's with us. Whether we're on
the mountaintop or in the valley,
whether we're in the fire or celebrating
something good, he's with us. So, let's
sing these words tonight and try to find
an honest place where you can say, "God,
I'm trusting that you are good even when
it doesn't feel like it. I want to trust
that you're going to come through."
All right, let's go ahead and start this
song.
I love you, Lord.
Oh, your mercy never fails me.
All my days
I've been held in your hands.
From the moment that I wake up
until I lay my head,
I will sing
of the goodness
of God.
All my life you have been faithful.
>> All my life you have been so so
with every breath that I am able.
>> I will sing of the goodness
of God.
I love your voice.
You have led me through the fire
in darkest nights.
You are close like no other.
I've known you as a father.
I've known you as a friend.
I have lived in the goodness
of God.
And all my life you have been faithful.
>> And all my life you have been so so
good.
With every breath that I am able
I see
of the goodness
of God.
Your goodness is running after. It's
running after me.
>> Your goodness is running after. It's
My life laid down. I surrender now. I
give you everything.
>> Your goodness is running after. It's
running after me.
It's running after
me.
All my life you have been in pain.
All my life you have been so so
with every breath that I am able
I will sing
of the goodness
of God.
I will sing of the goodness of God.
I will sing
of the goodness
of God.
[Music]
moved by the sound of his voice.
Se that are steny.
[Music]
And through it all, through it all, my
eyes are on you.
>> Through it all, through it all.
>> Through it all, through it all. My eyes
are on you. You did well
with me.
Father,
even when my eyes can see
this mountain that's in front of me.
will be thrown into the midst of the
sea.
Through it all, through it all, my eyes
are on you.
Through it all, through it all.
Through it all, through it all. My eyes
are on you.
It is well.
It is worth
all my soul
and trust in him. The waves of wind
still know his name.
Let all my soul
and trust in him. The ways of him still
know
his name.
For the ways of men still know his name.
>> And it is well
[Music]
with my soul.
It is well
[Music]
with my soul.
>> It is well
[Music]
with my soul.
It is well.
It is well
with my soul.
[Music]
It is well
with my soul.
Oh,
it is well
with my soul.
[Music]
It is well.
It is well
with my soul.
It is well.
It is well
with
my soul.
It is well.
It is well
my
[Music]
eyes are on you.
Through it all, through it all.
>> Through it all, through it all. My eyes
are on you. And it is well
with me.
Cuz all my life you have been faithful.
>> And all my life you have been so so
good.
With every breath that I am,
I will sing
of the goodness
of God.
Scott, I'm so grateful that your
faithfulness sometimes
looks like celebration and joy
and sometimes it looks like helping us
draw the next breath, takes the ne take
the next step, wake up each morning.
God, I pray that we would hang on to it,
whatever it looks like in this season,
and we would remember, God,
that surely goodness and mercy will
follow us all the days of our life.
Surely, you will continue to see us
through this next season.
Surely, you will lead us out of the
valley of the shadow of death.
God, help us to hold those two things in
unison. Help us to remember
that you're a good God, even when things
are not good.
We want to trust you.
We want to have the faith to believe,
God, that you will continue to be good
and to be with us through it all
in Jesus name. Amen.
Yeah. All right. Will you guys go ahead
and turn to the person beside you and
say, "The peace of Christ be with you.
All right. So, we've got something
really special uh tonight and uh it's
sort of a bitter bittersweet night.
We'll start with the the sweet is and if
you're currently on the elder team, if
you go ahead and come forward um and
join me up here. So, back in uh kind of
late 2024, we the the current elder
leadership team come in close. Come in
close. uh and kind of started I'm just
requesting some uh basically feedback
for potential new um the names of of
potential new elders and we always want
to kind of include the congregation in
that you know in that process
[Music]
and um so um we so that was kind of 2004
then so in January we sent out we kind
of based on y'all's feedback we sent out
some invites to some folks to basically
invite them into a process of discerning
and um usually that's supposed to be
like you know like 3 to four months and
instead it's kind of like become like
nine months um and so which is good
though it gave people lots of time to
kind of discern and so I am uh yeah I'm
really happy to announce some names
tonight of folks who have uh joined the
team and so if you will give me a hand
welcoming Megan and Christian Gay
Herring
they come forward there y'all. And also,
oh, was Megan out there? Um, and then is
Marcy or Marcy? Is Marcy Clark? Oh,
there she is at the back. Come on
forward, Marcy. All right, come in
close. Come in close, everyone. We got
to at least pretend like we like each
other. Okay,
>> here we go.
So, uh, I am I'm so excited for these
folks to join. Um, not only because as
you can see with like kind of one, two,
three, four, five, like the team was
kind of we had had a few other people
you know the previous had left so it was
like kind of getting small. Um, but it's
not just adding more people. It really
is. is I mean y'all know I mean these
are the names of people you wanted you
know what I mean you gave input to have
join us and you know like their love for
Jesus their commitment to this community
like it's just absolutely in it's
incredible and uh and really even in
these nine months we've seen like they
are pouring their hearts into what
they're doing so um yeah so we're just
incredibly grateful for them and I just
to give you a kind of for those who are
kind of like what is elder leadership
team What is what exactly is this about?
This is like just a snippet of the um
kind of the the job description. Um so
it says this. While it may at first
appear as a somewhat glamorous position,
the truth is that being on this
leadership team is mostly behind the
scenes work. It is prayer, meetings, and
being responsible for decisions. It's
counseling, listening, and seeking to
fill the leadership gaps even when an
area may not be your passion. It is
receiving criticism with grace and being
responsible for who this community
becomes. In short, it's mostly a lot of
work. And yet, there is joy here, too.
You get a front row seat to see this
community grow into something beautiful
in the knowledge that God used your
faithful service to help it flourish.
So, that's what these folks are signing
up for and uh we could not be more
excited uh to have them join us. So,
what we'd like to do is if gray
herrings, Marcy, if you all would kind
of come here more in the center and
we're just going to um we're going to
pray for y'all and I would like to kind
of to have y'all be able to participate
in this if you could just extend if
you're comfortable doing this. You don't
like have to, but I would love if you
would extend your hand just as a sign of
like blessing and um and kind of joining
us in this prayer um as I as I pray over
these these three. So Lord Jesus,
you promised that you would build your
church and that the gates of hell would
not prevail against it. And although
there is so much hatred and violence and
despair in this world, you have not
failed in your promise. And you continue
to call leaders like Marcy Christian
Megan to step forward to give of
themselves so that a community of Christ
can be made possible for others.
We thank you for them. We bless them in
their willingness to say yes to you and
to us. And we ask that you encourage,
embolden, and sustain them for the
journey ahead. May all of us live lives
marked by the humility and compassion of
you, our savior, Jesus Christ. Amen.
All right. If y'all kind of Yeah, you
can spread back out a little bit and I'm
going to pass it to Maggie for this next
part.
Yes. So we have beginnings and then we
have some endings and I get to be in
charge of the ending part. Um so this
man right here um Don has been not only
part of the table from the beginning I
was thinking back on um who Don is and
the words that came to mind were Don you
didn't just shape who the table has
become. You are the reason the table
exists.
And
I say that because we linked up with Don
um at a previous church that um is where
our journey started of becoming
affirming. And Don was one of the first
gay friends I've ever had.
And um it's all because of them, y'all.
No, but the truth is um it was people
like Don who moved the needle and Gary
was there for that. Gary was on the
elder team of that previous church um
along with Brett and myself, Gary's wife
Karen and um a good friend Wanita. And
during those days,
if you know Don, he is one of those
people who asks very little of anyone
and just receives what's given to him
and is so content with it. And here we
were at a non-affirming church and he
was like, I'm just so grateful to be
here and, you know, with people who, you
know, can love on me and blah blah blah.
And this has been such a and we weren't
even in affirming community at that
point. And he's seeing the goodness of
it and thanking God for it. And um it
was, you know,
now the rest is history. You know, now
we stand here today because of people
like Don who changed our hearts because
we realized this guy is not just good to
sit in the seat and you know like fill a
chair. He has giftings that should be
used and he has gifts that we want to
encourage and we want to see people like
him flourish and we cannot deny the Holy
Spirit in this man. So for that reason,
we have to start something different.
And that's why we're here. And I
I would I would be skipping a big part
of the story if I only talked about the
ways that Don impacted the church
because the truth is
you changed me.
Don and I grew up very similar
backgrounds in very conservative
evangelical spaces. And when Don came
into my life, I was still on the fence
like, I don't know what to do. I'm
starting to meet all these people who
I'm rubbing shoulders with and you know
what I mean? I I'm not sure what I think
and it doesn't fit into my theology or
anything I've been taught. And here's
Don wrapping his arm around me and
letting me go through the process of
figuring out my own theology that has a
huge impact on people like him. And
that's the kind of person you are. You
make space for people's processes.
And one of the reasons I've loved having
Don on the Elder team is because Don
really doesn't care much about building
churches. He really cares about people
and connecting with people. And he's
always the man in the back that's
keeping pulse of like did it did anybody
notice I saw someone come in and I I can
tell I can tell they are they have some
needs they and he would bring those
things up to the elder team and just no
one else would even know but he was
tracking. I saw someone walk in. I could
tell like they have some needs that we
need to to meet. can somebody reach out
to them? Or he's the one that's back in
the back talking to, you know, whoever's
in the nursery because he knew they were
going through a hard season and just
needed someone to process with that
night. Don,
it's your heart for people that makes
you so like Jesus. And I'm so grateful
for the ways that you've impacted us.
And um so Don and his husband Will in
the back are moving to North Carolina
this next week um to be close to family.
And that in of itself is a huge
huge massive change since we first met.
I never thought that day would come and
um it's amazing to see the journey that
Don's been on and now with Will and the
idea of him being able to reconnect with
his husband, with family who a while
back we were praying, you know what I
mean? We were praying for those
relationships. Um, so it is with deep
joy and great sadness that we send him
off um because we love him so much. But
um we did want to just celebrate who
he's been in this community. So, um,
after the service, Allison has gathered
some just treats and some cookies and,
um, beverage for us to share so that
people can get a chance to mingle with
Don. And if you know Don or if he's
impacted you in any way, please grab
him. Please let him know how special he
is and how much, um, he means to us. And
we also have a gift for you that's out
there. Um, but for the rest of you, most
we tried to do as much ahead of time as
possible in getting signatures. Um, but
if you haven't had a chance to sign
Don's gift and would like to do that, it
will also be out there on that table,
um, for anyone that we might have
missed. So, um, that being said, I want
to send you off with a blessing. And if
you guys could just pray with me this
one last time.
God, we send Don off
confirming the good work that you do and
have done in him
and that you have done through him.
And we say thank you. We thank you for
his influence on our lives, the way that
he touched us personally.
And God, just the ways that he's
ministered here
in the unseen spaces,
in the in the moments where no one else
is watching or would even know,
and he's taking care of people. And God,
I just pray that you would return to
Dawn
over and above what he could ever ask. I
pray for him and Will both that this
next season would be so marked by
richness and goodness and joy. God, I
pray that the relationships with family
would be just um a totally refreshing
experience for them and um that those
reconnections would be sweet. God, we
pray um your um blessing over them in
every way, emotionally, spiritually, um
financially, God, that you would meet
every need that they have, that you
would take such good care of them. And
we send them off knowing that um they
are beautiful reflections of who you
are. And we affirm that. And I just ask
that as they go, God, they would
continue to affirm that in other people
who need it so desperately. It's in
Jesus name that we pray. Amen.
We love you, Don.
Yeah, y'all can clap for Don.
Beginnings and endings, they're a big
deal, you know, and uh sometimes like
celebratory and beautiful and sometimes
really hard but important, you know,
important nonetheless. Press into some
of those feelings. So, um yeah. So, we
are, let's see, we're beginning a new
three-part series tonight. And we got
actually got some I'd say a few two kind
of I don't know what do you call juicy
series. I don't know. It's like a it's
going to be a little a little
theologically edgy probably because
we're going to do three weeks on
scripture. So, it's titled the good
book, fresh insights into an ancient
text. So, that'll be three weeks on this
and then we're going to do three weeks
on esquetology, which is like uh the the
sort of end of all things. Uh, and you
know, people often wonder what's Brett's
take on the book of Revelation, you
know, whatever. Although I won't, it
will not be some line by line exesus of
the book of Revelation. I'll tell you
that. Um, actually for reasons that will
come become apparent in this uh series.
But um nonetheless, I think it'll be I'm
hopeful it will be helpful and
uh just as kind of a well yeah I'll just
name I my intention isn't to like shoot
anyone's wheels off or you know um so if
you have kind of questions on where I'm
coming from um especially even this
sermon of this this message in ways is
kind of an introduction to the series as
a whole and at times it might sound like
almost like a I don't know if I am I
like a skeptic or something and you know
rest assured I'm like I'm a Christian. I
think if anything um and I think this
will become clear as I go, but I I am
worried that a certain a particular take
or an interpretation largely in
Protestant circles uh of the Christian
church has at times elevated the Bible
over Christ. And I think that's a huge
issue. So that's that's sort of just so
you know where I'm coming from. It's if
it sounds kind of like geez man, you're
like kind of hard on it like you're do
you even believe the Bible or do you you
know whatever. And just know I love the
Bible. I I read it like every day. Have
devoted a lot of my life to like
studying it and reflecting on it. But uh
yeah, but there's there's some things we
need to kind of think through here. So
anyway, so just so you know, that's kind
of where I'm I'm coming from. So the um
so the title of my message is scripture
uh more than a book. Um that's the
message for tonight. And so our primary
text is from Luke 24 um verses 25- 27.
Just for a little background, this is
the the kind of famous story of the
disciples on the road to Emmas. So just
you know, so this is kind of right after
it's after the crucifixion and
technically even after the resurrection
though these disciples don't know that
they've like heard rumors of like
resurrection. They heard you know some
of the women who were there at the empty
tomb but they're just still kind of like
what is going on you know. So they leave
Jerusalem. They're on the road to
literally this town called Emmas, like
seven miles outside Jerusalem when a man
comes up to them, catches up with them.
It's Christ. They don't realize this. We
don't know exactly what that is. This
actually is a common theme with Jesus in
his kind of resurrected body. It was
like at times people I don't know if
it's like a a spiritual thing like where
he's sort of I don't know doing some
Jedi mind trick where they can't quite
discern who he you know or if it's
something he's just kind of looks a
little bit different or is covered with
a ro you know we're not sure but they
don't recognize him and he's like you
know what's going on and they're like
you haven't heard like it's like all
Jerusalem's talking about this and
they're you know they he's they're
walking from Jerusalem to you know so
they know he's been there like so uh
they bring him into the loop on like
well this man Jesus D and we thought he
was a prophet then he was killed but
then there's rumors of resurrection you
know and uh that's that we kind of pick
up the story there in verse 25 then
Jesus said to them how foolish you are
and how slow to believe all that the
prophets have spoken again not because
they were so much like skeptical but
they were just confused they were just
like we don't know what to make of this
you know
uh did not the Messiah have to suffer
these things and then enter his glory
and beginning with Moses and all the
prophets. He explained to them what was
said in all the scriptures concerning
himself. So I got to name this isn't
necessarily, you know, like I've
mentioned, this isn't a series about,
you know, the resurrection or the road
to Emmas or so I'm not going to focus in
on all that. Instead, I'm really
interested in that phrase, the
scriptures. The scriptures, what was
Jesus talking about there? Like what
what does he have in mind? Because
growing up, I don't know about you, I
definitely envisioned something like
Jesus, you know, reaching into his back
pocket and pulling out his King James
version Bible, you know, and he page by
page, you know, or book by he flipped
through it and he was like, "Look at
this in Isaiah and look at, you know, I
mean, he's kind of that's kind of the
visual um I had." And uh, of course,
that's that's not how it worked, right?
He pulled nothing out of his back
pocket. Not because he didn't have a
pocket, though he maybe he didn't. I'm
not sure about robes back then, but
because he did not have a Bible,
right? There was there was no physical
book called a Bible yet. You know what I
mean? So, uh that's where this is, uh
kind of off now. Um okay. So, why does
this matter? Well, I think it it matters
because the issue is, you know, when it
comes to phrases like, oh, the Bible or
the scriptures and such, we tend to be
very uh to use kind of like what do they
call these? A $5 word, $10, whatever.
Uh, anacronistic. It's like a big old
word. So, what does anacronistic mean?
Anacronistic means belonging to a period
other than that being portrayed. Like if
you're watching a film about uh it was
like a western set, you know, like 1832
and you noticed someone's drinking from
a can of Coca-Cola, you know, that would
be like, but nope. You know, it's it's
in the wrong age. And that's the same
thing we do, right, when we envision
Jesus pulling out his KJV is like, well,
nope, nope, that wasn't there, right?
Wasn't in that time. So, right, when I
um and but this is what we're tempted to
do, right? And it's normal like when I
read here, oh the scriptures in my own
kind of Protestant mind, you know, it's
easy to kind of, oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. I know, I know what
that's, you know, what that's talking
about. Um, it's, you know, it's the
Bible. But of course that is that's a
very modern Protestant kind of Christian
vision of what scripture is because
actually for thousands of years in
Judaism and then for really hundreds of
years after the crucifixion,
resurrection and ascension of Jesus uh
the the church uh actually functioned
with a very what we would probably call
at least we would think of it today as
like a very kind of loosey goosey or
kind of fluid view of what exactly
scripture is. Um or we could say even
what is or is not scripture. Now why why
was that? I'm going to give you two
interconnected reasons and hang with me.
Some of this is a little um I know it's
like heavy teaching kind of message. At
the end I'll try to get into some
implications that like kind of matter
for our life and such but um yeah let's
kind of I want to set this up though. So
two reasons um why this was the first
was technological in nature. The second
was historical. So we'll talk about the
technology. So the most obvious insight
is that as I've kind of hinted at, books
as a technological medium did not exist
until about 500 years ago, right? So
um it's weird though because we don't
think of books as technology.
You know what I mean? Like if someone's
like, I got this cool technology, a
book, you know, you're like, that's not
technology, man. A computer is, you
know, but you can imagine in a world
without books, it's kind of like, whoa,
what's that? Oh, yes. you know, it's
like a book, you know. So, it it really
is it's a it's a technology that was
invented. And of course, Jesus walked
the earth, you know, 2,000 years ago.
Judaism is, you know, even older than
that. So, if you you can see the math
there. 500 years ago, 2,000 years ago,
we got a big gap of time where there's
no, you know, there's not physical
books. And so, you can kind of see the
problem here, right? The printing press
in essence changed the world. And and
here's the key because you say, "Well,
yeah, okay, but it was still the Bible
or the scripture was still there. Just
it wasn't in a book." But what I want to
name is when you put it into a new
technological medium, you know what I
mean? When you put it together in that
way, it changes how you start to think
about it. It changes like what you think
scripture is, what what is and is not
scripture, right? And this is um why I
for like many years, you know, envision
Jesus taking out his trusty King James
um when of course that didn't exist not
only as just the Bible, but even as like
that exact version of the Bible with
those specific books and that ex those
exact number of chapters in each book,
you know what I mean? Like even that
kind of um
yeah, kind of version, it didn't it just
wasn't uh a thing. So what did they have
before that? Well, what they had was
various writings on scrolls,
right? So in other words, you had like
this scroll over here, you know, in this
synagogue with the story of Genesis and
then that scroll. They also might have
had Genesis might have been a little
different like slightly in the lingo or
words or um this happened a lot with the
book of Psalms like the in terms of the
psalms being like okay it's 150 people
150 and that is it. uh back in the
ancient world more lucy because how many
psalms are there?
in process, you know, like some people
say and of more this synagogue says 130,
that one says 140. Uh this one's 155,
you know, and which psalms were written
by David.
You know, we're kind of feeling it out.
There's there's it's kind of loosey
goosey. Um in fact, there was even
scroll a scroll found at Kuman, the that
famous cave of Kuman that said David
wrote over 4,000 psalms. Now scholars
don't know is this like kind of
exaggerating or if it you know or but it
kind of opens up the question of like I
don't know does is there like like what
if they found another 300 psalms and
then Christian churches kind of have to
debate like oh I don't know do we it
seems to be written by David do we
include them in the you know what I mean
so uh this is is kind of how things were
and it was very much the same when it
comes to the writings of the New
Testament somewhat um kind of you know
loosey goosey ad hoc process. So you
had, you know, this little church over
here, they've got a copy of Galatians,
and this church is like, "Can you give
us a copy of Galatians?" And they're
like, "Sure, we'll just copy this down."
You know, and they have the book of
Romans, but they don't have the book of
Romans yet, you know, or whatever. Like
it was this kind of evolving um organic
kind of process. Um in fact there's even
um other writings that were very
important in the early church like the
the writing called the uh the shepherd
of Hermass which many people many
Christians really believed Christian
leaders really thought should be
included in the New Testament like it
was that important to churches back in
the day and people did like certain
churches treated it really like um like
scripture and and then of course
everything's being copied by hand right
so later it was done by like monks who
were quite scrupulous and all that, but
you know, early on it wasn't necessarily
uh the case. Like the first person to
copy the book of Romans wasn't like, "Oh
my gosh,
I'm copying
holy scripture."
You know what I mean? They're just like,
"Ah, that church needs these writings.
They really like them." You know what I
mean? Uh so the the process it was just
uh yeah, a little more loosey goosey
than than some of us might uh imagine.
So, okay. So that's kind of the the
first thing, right, is this whole thing
of like the technology of scrolls and
copies and versions and how many
chapters in that book and you know all
this is is kind of floating around. It's
just a little bit different. So um so
this technology of scrolls verse books
really impacts how a person thinks about
what scripture is because you know in a
book I can hand it to someone and I can
say here is all of scripture right here
you know when it's kind of collections
of scrolls
scattered across the continent you know
this kind of holy writings are there.
You know, it's kind of like a little bit
unwieldy, you know what I mean? Like
it's it's a little you can see where
it's it's uh yeah, just more fluid these
kind of scattered writings um that
really only over time as the tradition
develops do certain writings come to be
seen in this way. So uh that of course
leads us to the second point history. So
the historical so with that differing
technology that led into a very
different a and much more relaxed
history of what's called canonization
uh another big word but canonization is
the process of basically making a bible
right the process of evaluating
collecting arranging divinely inspired
writings into a specific authoritative
list that serves as the standard for
religion's beliefs and practices like so
for example like if you were inventing a
religion today you would have to think
through ahead of time okay guys what's
going to go into our book,
right? You'd have to because books are a
thing. However,
if you don't have books, you aren't
thinking in terms of what's going to go
into our official book,
right? So the history of really what was
at first kind of verbal accounts and
then eventually the technology of
scrolls leads to this kind of evolving
organic collection um of writings and it
and it leads to a very different mindset
about scripture and revelation
because when you have kind of a book
it's sort of like God spoke and here it
is whereas when you have these kind of
scrolls and writings what you have is
this mindset of kind of God is speaking
and we have this evolving collection of
holy writings that is becoming
increasingly important to at first
Jewish communities and then later
Christian communities but it's not until
400 years after the you know life death
resurrection ascension of Jesus that we
actually um certain wings of the church
are like okay okay okay okay
let's get some clarity here we need like
the official, you know, kind of list and
they finally start kind of pinning down
the list of like New Testament books
that you find in your Bible today. But
even then, many church leaders, you
know, they differed in what they thought
should or should not make the cut. This
is my most uncomfortable day in Bible
college. Uh I was at a Southern Baptist
school. you know, of course, we're all
about scripture. And then we learned how
the Bible actually came together and
we're kind of like, "Oh gosh, they're
like voting."
Like they weren't sure, you know what I
mean? It was deeply profoundly
uncomfortable. Uh so
like for example, uh St. Cire of
Jerusalem, hugely influential back then,
he was very concerned about already
hinted at this, the book of Revelation.
They love I think they loved it from the
it is kind of a great ending in a way
like ah you know old Jerusalem new
Jerusalem you know I mean it's kind of
like it feels like ah it's everything's
some it's perfect but then there's like
some of the other aspects of it deeply
allegorical you know it could be
interpreted in a ton of ways and St. I
real saw that a group called the
Montinists were like taking it and
running with it. They were like, "This
is awesome. This is like the greatest
Christian writing ever." And they were
really getting into it and he's like,
"Oh no, oh no, no, don't don't include
it." Um, but they ended up including it.
And I mean, it's fascinating, right, to
think of books of the Bible as like
actual history. And like there's
actually moments where churches were
deciding what to include and what not to
include. Here's kind of the way the
Eastern Orthodox theologian John Bear
put it in his wonderful book in
accordance with the scriptures. He says
this, "Rather than thinking about
scripture as a bound book with two
testaments or bodies of literature and a
canonical listing in order, it is better
to think of scripture as a field of
literature with certain texts being more
central such as Genesis, Exodus, Isaiah,
Psalms, etc., and others more marginal.
For example, Bell and the Dragon, uh,
which is an alternative ending to the
book of Daniel, that is in Catholic and
Eastern Orthodox Christian Bibles, but
not yours, not the ones that are here on
these chairs.
Um, he continues, uh, so bell and drag
with, uh, different versions of the same
texts, different collections of texts
within books. For example, the psalms,
that's back to that. Well, how many
psalms exactly? Well, it came kind of
different and many different ways of
reading these texts. That's very
important, right? Even if you have the
same Bible, it's like there's lots of
interpreting going on.
So, the way I'd kind of maybe summarize
that and put it into my own kind of
language is to say for early Judaism and
Christianity, scripture was and for many
continues to be seen as a kind of open
evolving archive of holy writings with
some texts being more central, for
example, the gospels and others more
marginal. uh like for example third
John, book of revelation, certainly the
ending bell and dragon um but others uh
as well. So now am I saying like this is
how most evangelicals view scripture? Uh
no. Um what I'm saying is this is the
historical process that led scripture to
be what it is. And I think that should
influence how we think about it in
essence. Um,
well, I'll just kind of continue. So,
some of the implications of this, what,
like, what does this actually mean for
how we, you know, view and think about
scripture? Uh, number one, release rigid
categories.
Release rigid categories. When I think
of what a a kind of religious
fundamentalism is like all about, it's
it's really not. A lot of times I have a
lot of similar beliefs to Christian
fundamentalists. Like, I'm here for
Jesus resurrection and ascension and
like all the thing. Sure. Yes. You know,
it's not so much just the beliefs. It's
like how you believe.
You know, a kind of desperation for like
certainty
in an uncertain world that causes us to
kind of grab our beliefs with a death
grip and then wield them like a sword or
something, you know, and people do that
a lot with the Bible. But I hope you can
see I just think the Bible isn't up for
that. It's simply, it's just not some
neat, tidy, perfect little text that
just dropped from the heavens fully
formed
and is somehow beyond dispute. In other
words, right, a fundamentalist really
has to ignore a lot of history in order
to turn scripture into this very rigid
King James thing. Um, second
implication, we need to read the text
with discernment,
right? Like this beautiful messy
evolving process means that we do in
fact have to interpret and and carefully
use discernment when we read and
interpret that text. Right? The Bible is
just not some flat book where every
passage is as important or even as
theologically accurate.
We'll get more into this in future
sermons as every other passage.
Right? Again, kind of let that sink in.
I think most Christians
uh especially from the tradition many of
us come from aren't thinking of the
Bible in this way, right? They think
some random passage in Leviticus is
every bit as important and essential to
the like the gospels as say the
teachings of Christ in the sermon on the
mount.
Uh I I think this is insane. So they
right um
now of course they would look at me in
this sermon and they would say you are
changing how we view scripture you know
and I would say well no I'm trying to go
back to how we used to think about it
before you changed it that's what I'm
that's what I'm getting at so in other
words right people love and I think we
just love simple ideas we do so we love
a simple approach something like the
Bible says it and that settles it you
know no you have to read the Bible with
your brain fully on and asking the
question, does this align with the
nature and character of Christ? Because
if read solely at the literal level,
there are passages which do not. There
are ways of interpreting the book of say
Revelation that are downright
antichrist, which is ironic since it is
a book so concerned with the antichrist.
All right. Third, look for Christ's
unveiling. This is essential because if
you're listening, you're like, "Is this
guy even a Christian?" I am. And this is
like this is uh this is why I think
Christ is so central. We'll get more
into this next week, but as you read the
scriptures, ask yourself um how does
this passage open me to the presence of
Christ today. As I've said before, the
the point of scripture is to point us to
Jesus.
That's the point of scripture, right?
The point of scripture is not to point
back to itself,
right? It's not to help people believe
in it. It's not even about defending the
church or getting people to believe in
the church, right? No. No. These books
were only included because people felt
that in whole or sometimes in part they
could point to Christ. Fourth, be
inspired to read beyond scripture. Uh
some Christians get very weird about the
Bible where they start to think, you
know, kind of like God can only be
speaking through this text and not any
other, you know. Uh but from all we've
discussed, I hope you can see the Bible
that we have today is kind of nested
within like circles of other texts that
themselves can open up our heart and
mind. Right? In other words, rather than
viewing scripture and God's written
revelation as some sort of like walled
garden,
what if we saw it like a beautiful field
of flowers? And at the center of the
field are flowers called the gospels.
And then out from there is Paul's
writings. And then a little further out
from there Isaiah and the Psalms in
Genesis. And then a little further away
is the desert fathers. And then maybe
Thomas Aquinas or I don't know maybe
Plato's somewhere out there. And Richard
Ro and Peterins and Rachel Held Evans. I
think she's it's you know she's in the
field somewhere. You know what I mean?
And in other words, God's revelation is
it's not something to be kind of like
defended and agonized over or pinned
down, but something to open ourselves
to. So hopefully um in closing the
sermon has piqued your interest and not
shot your wheels off too much. I really
think as a church, especially as folks
kind of wrestling with scripture in in
ways getting over a kind of um not the
best of the evangelical tradition, but
we we're wrestling with the worst of it.
Um that uh we can we need a more
relaxed, less rigid, more playful, more
spiritually minded um approach to uh the
Bible. And so hopefully this series will
help us do that. In the name of the
father, the son, and the holy spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held the loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take it. Eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you." And he held the cup of
wine. He said, "Take it and drink. This
is my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me. So, as we come
forward, we connect with the risen
Christ. And uh the way we'll kind of go
about that tonight is we'll just go
rowby row. We'll start here at the front
and just form one line um here in the
middle. We uh it's a practice an open
table. So, if you're here tonight, you'd
like to participate, then you're totally
free to do that. Um, you should just
know that the red is wine, the white is
grape juice. And finally, you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some people take it immediately, some
like to come and kneel here at the
front. Some return to their seats, but
no one will lead you through the exact
moment of taking of the elements. So,
this is the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord, and
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more.
So come, come you who have much faith
and you who have little. You who have
been here often and you who have not
been here long. You who have tried to
follow and you who have failed. Come.
Come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
If you guys would like to stand with us,
we're going to close out with Christ be
All around Around Me
You guys sing along.
[Music]
Strength of God.
Go.
Lift me up.
as
a guide.
Look upon
in my side
as I wait
God
[Music]
satisfied
as I hear
voice of
[Music]
Be my God.
Above and below me, before and behind
me, in every eye that sees me. Christ me
all around me, above and below me,
before and behind me, in every eye that
see me. Christ be all around me
as I go.
Hand of God.
My defense
by my side
as I rest
in the dark.
Father,
bring me peace.
Bring me peace
above and below me, before and behind
me, in every eye that sees me. Christ be
all alove
and below me, before and behind me, in
every eye that sees me. Christ be all
around me.
Oh wo.
Christ be all around me.
Yeah.
Oh wo.
Christ be all over me. Yeah.
Your life, your death, your blood was
shed for every moment,
every moment. Your life, your death,
your blood was shed for every moment,
every moment. Your life, the death. Your
blood was shed
for every moment.
Every moment your light, your death,
your blood will shed
for every moment,
every
moment.
Love and lonely
before and behind me, in every eye that
sees me.
Christ be all around me, above and below
me, before and behind me, in every eye
that sees me. Christ be all around me.
Oh wo.
Christ be all around me.
[Music]
Well, thank you one more time for being
with us tonight, especially if this was
your first time. We hope you felt
welcomed and at ease and um we hope to
get to know you better if we haven't
caught you yet. Um there is a visitors
card over here on this table to my left
that you can sign and fill out so that
we can get your contact information. Um
or there's a QR code that will be up on
the screen that you can sign uh scan and
you can sign um that visitor card
virtually if you'd rather go through
that method. And um that will also link
you to the welcome to the table class
that's coming up in two weeks. Um we'll
end up with the children's sign up for
our fall fest on that through that same
link. So that just use that as much as
you need it. Um, and as you leave, if
you have not connected to our community
and you've been here for a while and are
needing more connection, the way that we
do that at the table is through meetups.
And um, those are groups that get
together throughout the week, spread out
and we have different ones in different
locations. And we really urge you being
connected to a community outside of just
the busyiness of coming into a service,
sitting in a chair, and walking out the
doors is truly where you're going to
find the life of the church. And so we
encourage you to do that. And you can
find out more about meetups through that
QR code or speak with Megan and
Christian Grey Herring who were up here
earlier and they can get you more
information about one in your area. Um,
we will have refreshments in the lobby
um as we send Dawn off. So, I do
encourage you to grab him if you get a
chance and um hug his neck before he
leaves and sign his um gift. And um
other than that, it is my privilege to
send you off with our benediction
tonight. So, you are welcome to stand.
You can open your hands in a posture to
receive if um you would like to or bow
your head with me. But I'd love to speak
this over you.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. And this is true
on your best day and this is true on
your worst. So as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between, go filled with the assurance
that you are loved, that you are worthy,
and that you are accepted just as you
are. and go filled with God's spirit and
the desire to share these gifts of
unconditional grace and love with
everyone that you come into contact
with. Amen.
You are dismissed.
[Music]
Every eye that sees me.